das können wir jetzt diese theorie
ich habe mich mal wieder auf youtube
rumgetrieben und habe dort einen kanal
gefunden der heiße tipp scribe das ist
die beschreibung von seinem video auf
dass wir heute reagieren werden freunde
und vorweg erst mal wenn youtuber eine
gewisse anzahl von abonnenten genen dann
ist es gang und gäbe dass bei einer
rundenzahl ein special gemacht wird also
beispielsweise bei 100000 hunderttausend
vielleicht sogar einer million der liebe
den hat sich allerdings daran gedacht
hey ich brauche doch nicht wirklich
abonnenten um ein special zu machen ich
mache doch einfach 1 0 chips treiber
special sondern auch noch falsch
geschrieben und dieses video hat sage
und schreibe an die 600.000 aufrufe ihr
seht schon freunde dass das ganze video
nicht mehr in hd hochgeladen wurde und
nicht mal einen passenden format also
deswegen ist dass gerade so komische
abgeschnitten aber wir schauen uns das
video jetzt mal zusammen an
wie calmy-rey dass dieser kleine junge
namens denn vor der kamera und schaut
sich erstmal um ist ein bisschen
verwirrt und sagt ich nehme dieses video
hier auf weil naja bisher hat noch
niemand mich abonniert aber mal schauen
wie das ganze nicht jetzt weitergeht
freunde also ich krieg mal wieder direkt
auf play o
da sitzt doch jemand seine mutter
er hat gerade gesagt dass seine oma die
neben ihm sitzt jetzt gerade ihn
abonniert hat das heißt sein erster
abonnenten
du hast es das ist kein safe search
server special es ist ein zero
subscriber space
das ist eine aufforderung an die leute
die sich das video anschauen das
harmonieren sollen aber er hat ja noch
gar nichts hochgeladen
also dieses video hier gehen jetzt eine
minute und er hat in dieser einen minute
gesagt dass er noch keine abonnenten hat
aber seine oma die neben ihm sitzt
gerade in frisch abonniert hatte und das
nächste sketch bekommt bei 100
abonnenten das ist schön zu hören
allerdings hat er auch bei einem
abonnenten dann entsprechen hochgeladen
dieses video hier von den hat er am
gleichen tag hochgeladen die seien die
betreiber special der es trägt den titel
sonst hab sie es es hat fast eine
million aufrufe aufrufe und in der
beschreibung steht des försters treiber
his grandma das heißt nachdem seine oma
jetzt im letzten video abonniert hat
dankt er ihr jetzt dafür
okay es war kamera hinstellen macht man
nicht form video das macht man wirklich
es im video dann werden die leute wollen
natürlich sehen dass du hier bist also
mal weiterschauen hier was ich liebe
dich jetzt gefragt diese sketchen für
eine retail so jetzt endlich ist jetzt
habe auch wirklich verifiziert
angekommen auf seinem kanal so dass er
der held seiner oma extra verdankt also
der ist echt hammer kerl aber ich würde
sagen wie kriegen wir direkt weiter hier
auf play das echt granma großen respekt
dass du ihn abonniert hast
okay er macht vielleicht noch was sagt
er gerade mal schauen ja leute ich
stelle das ganze video jetzt mal nach
hier für euch auf deutsch ich bin der
luca ich habe jetzt einen abonnenten das
ist meine oma dank vielleicht support
ich würde das video zu beenden
ich mache noch was und zwar
nee ich mache auch nichts mehr
bei und ich habe den euch verlinkt und
in der beschreibung checkten aus gröst
den von mir größten von luxo alter
stellt euch mal vor der macht der in
video walkthrough von sony music school
wird
[Musik]
ich meine er sagt ja gerade dass er das
nicht mal wieder was man macht bei 1000
abonnenten aber vorher hat schon 63.000
also das was das war's das
das ist
qualitativ hochwertiger content ein paar
sekunden später oh mein gott freunde ich
sehe gerade
dass der noch viel viel mehr abos
beschluss hochgeladen hat also das hier
ist jetzt ein sechseinhalb tausend
abonnenten special was drei tage später
kam also play ein bisschen stress mit
ihrer mutter weil er den nachnamen von
sich angeblich rausgehauen hat und die
mutter wollte das nicht an der stelle
respekt an die eltern finde ich gut wenn
die dahinter stehen um mein gott er hat
ein einwand second video hochgeladen
es wäre of water day vor allem geht das
video auch einfach zwei sekunden aber so
wie es hier aussieht hat er tatsächlich
kein 1000 abonnenten special hochgeladen
also er wollte ist ja anscheinend hoch
laden und die mutter hat es ihm verboten
weil sein nachname darin zu sehen war
das heißt wir schauen jetzt einfach sein
das ist ja was neues
[Musik]
wenn wir so gar nicht von mir okay
kräftig an
freunde ich hab da ja gerade mal an crd
mit euch darauf reagiert und no job das
ist mein lieblings youtuber neuerdings
freunde
haltet euch fest wir bewegen uns jetzt
ein ganzes stück vorwärts und zwar
schauen wir uns von denen das video 19,8
tausend abonnenten aus sozialen auch so
seit 1 1 aus
mit zwei minuten 47 ist das video sogar
relativ lang für seine verhältnisse eher
sagt toni 1000 aber im titel steht 19,8
oh mein gott was geht da ab alter also
die beiden haben sich jetzt geküsst mal
schauen ob wir vorne nur noch geredet
wird oder ob sie einfach nur hinter der
kamera weiter her schauen man sieht auch
nur die hälfte von den gesichtern von
denen die oma sieht man ganz ist es
natürlich wundervoll
[Musik]
er macht immer ab und zu mal eine
kollaboration mit seiner grandma kommt
die region bei gott was war das hier
gerade das hat wehgetan im herzen glaube
ich er hat
19.000 abonnenten
und sagt sein ziel ist es bei 1 holen
dane
wenigstens creams tubik also das ist ihr
hoch anzurechnen aber als es ist denn
dauert ein bisschen
also ich kaufe den tisch
er denkt
ihr wisst ja noch der denn der
eigentlich totale scheiße in seinen
videos macht gerade das er bis zu seiner
abonnenten zahlen noch ein bisschen viel
ist auf youtube 50 millionen sind 50
millionen mehr als den harz may be trieb
dann halt erst 2019 die 50 millionen
abonnenten
ja bitte schön für sie
[Musik]
ok freunde an der stelle an der stelle
würde ich dann hier mit jetzt auch das
heutige video beenden meine damen und
herren ich habe das video einfach bei
mir bei empfohlen gesehen und habe mir
gedacht warum wird mir eine null
abonnenten special empfohlen ab iran
gedacht okay das gucken wir zusammen mit
euch an sich fast auf jeden fall sehr
sehr lustig wie findet ihr den kanal
einschreiten kommentare könnt ihr
einfach sie roadster betreibers
babyschale eingeben bei youtube dann
findet er seinen kanal und kann den
selbst schon auschecken und so ist meine
damen und herren würde ich sagen müssen
jetzt an einem moment angekommen
division ja für mich der
lieblingsmomente weil man videos ist und
zwar